la France a été au rendez-vous depuis le
premier jour et je crois que c'est tout
à son honneur nous avons suspendu
immédiatement l'ensemble de nos
coopérations civiles et militaires nous
avons refusé d'tempérer lorsque la
jeunte a demandé le départ de notre
ambassadeur et le départ de nos forces
nous n'avons pas à obéir aux injonctions
euh d'un pouvoir illégal et illégitime
et nous avons continué de marquer notre
soutien au président Bazou et à la CDAO
le président de la République a annoncé
à la fois le retrait progressif de nos
forces armées et le rappel de notre
ambassadeur qui est rentré à Paris vous
l'avez vu il y a quelques jours pour
autant je
voudrais être très clair ce
retrait nécessaire puisque nos forces
armées étaient là à la demande d'un
gouvernement démocratique euh élu
légitimement représentant la volonté de
son peuple et pour assurer une mission
particulière qui était l'appui à la
lutte antiterroriste alors que les
bouistes n'ont rien de légitime et ne
luttent pas contre le terrorisme cette
décision nécessaire ne signifie en rien
un changement de notre position de
fond nous soutenons le président Bazou
nous demandons sa libération nous
continuons de soutenir les efforts de la
CDAO nous n'avons pas rompu nos relation
diplomatiqu avec le Niger et nous
n'avons pas non plus fermé notre
ambassade l'ambassade reste ouverte euh
avec une toute petite équipe à la
différence par exemple de ce que nous
avons dû faire au au Soudan donc notre
politique et ce qu'alé ambitieuse
volontariste et le sentiment
anti-français n'est pas du tout une
donnée dominante elle est peut-être dans
l'esprit de quelques bouchis qui
instrumentalisent euh des critiques à
l'endroit de notre pays alors qu'il
conduisent leur peuple et leur pays dans
la difficulté j'observe aussi mais vous
l'avez vu que ces euh agitations
antifrançaise avec force Drapor russe
viennent souvent dans un second temps ne
sont pas la motivation des populations
ni même la motivation du Poch que ces
généraux mènent ensuite apparaissent
d'autres drapeaux que le nôtre je vous
laisse conclure